in your book you're talking about
companies who are painkillers versus
vitamins could you talk a little bit
more about that sure
so there's kind of this religion about
vitamins versus painkillers that what we
teach MBAs today or what entrepreneurs
hear when they go out and try and raise
venture capital is that they want to
build a painkiller product right we
don't want to spend our time building
vitamins we want to build painkillers
painkiller products are the kind of
products that customers can tell you
they need right stop my pain they have
quantifiable markets and they're
eminently monetizable vitamins on the
other hand that's the kind of product
that people say yeah you know what I
don't think I want to back that kind of
project within an enterprise right your
boss or your PMO's and I don't really
that's a vitamin feature that's not
something we need to build let's build
the painkillers right so a reason that a
venture capital say you know what we're
gonna pass on that idea one of the
reasons might be you know it just
doesn't seem like something people
really need so that's the current way of
thinking I kind of challenged that way
of thinking because if you consider some
of the products that we've been talking
about that are very habit forming like
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram and
whatsapp these products didn't start out
as painkillers right nobody woke up
eleven years ago in the middle of the
night 2:00 in the morning shouting I
wish I could update my status right that
never happened before Facebook existed
so these products that become these
these painkillers over time they start
out as vitamins they start out as
nice-to-haves and they're frequently
dismissed people say oh it's just a
little toy right that's not gonna have a
big impact well it turns out that by
creating habits by becoming these
integral parts of people's day-to-day
lives they become pain killers as they
form these habits so today if Mark
Zuckerberg said you know what we're
gonna shut down Facebook I've made
enough money I'm done people would have
conniption fits right they would have a
big problem all of a sudden there's a
product that was a toy and was just a
vitamin has all of a sudden become a
painkiller and how do I know if my idea
is a painkiller or a vitamin that could
become a painkiller right so it comes
down to figuring out if you have these
hooks that if you you have very little
chance of forming a habit without having
this hook built into your product this
four step process that takes these
pleasure-seeking behaviors
and becomes these painkiller products